so when broke people say I can afford
this you know what they're saying I
think I might be able to pay the
payments that's what broke people mean
when they say that if you don't want to
be broke people anymore you get out of
the land of payments if you don't want
to be broke people anymore you sit down
and you say hey here's what we make
here's the size of our mess what are we
going to do to increase our income and
decrease our outgo to be able to address
the mess
faster it really is sixth grade or
fourth grade math
it really and truly is but you have to
get in front of it instead of running
behind it all the time getting in front
of it is you look at your situation
before you make a decision not after
you've made the
decision a
$444,000 SUV when you make $85,000 a
year is
stupid whether you paid cash for it or
not it's still stupid but when you
finance that it's double triple stupid